welcome today we're gonna dive into the
material in earnest start building a
foundation for thinking about natural
language understanding models before we
do that though I want to do just a few
logistical things because well frankly
because they're not so intuitive so let
me start with the least intuitive one of
all as I said last time we're going to
be using canvas to do all the submission
of work which basically means that
you're going to use it to upload
notebooks and I think that part is
straightforward because then we're going
to take those notebooks and evaluate
them separately outside of the system so
you don't have to deal with very much
data entry the one thing you do have to
confront if you want to work in groups
is actually joining a group and that's
the part on canvas that I find quite
strange so let me just walk you through
what life is like from my perspective
and understanding canvas here I'm logged
in as an instructor and I can get a feel
for what you all see when I choose the
student view so here I am in the student
view and this is what I hope happens for
you if you want to say form a group for
assignment one and bake-off one you go
to people I'm not sure why it's called
people I guess groups are made of people
okay and then choose the group's tab and
what it's going to do is load a ton of
free created groups that's the least
intuitive part of all for me that you
guys can't just create your own groups
under the rubric of assignment one but
rather that I have to create hundreds of
empty groups for you and then you can
join them on your own but what I see
that people have done it so I'm
reassured like for example this is a
group that has currently one person in
it and this one has two now I can't
verify that this works because it says
group is not available for me and I did
in a panic Google around and I
discovered that I think that's because
I'm merely a test student who can only
aspire to be a real student and a test
student can't actually join a group but
I am reassured that a bunch of people
have and so my assumption
is like if a few of you wanted to start
your own group what you would do is
scroll this endless list until you found
one that had the right name like a sign
one bake off one or a sign three bake
off three in the future claim it for
yourself so then you can all join and
then you formed a group so I hope that
works out for everyone and I'm just
recognizing that it's a kind of strange
system let us know if you see any
unusual behavior for this but once
you've done that then again I'm
reassured that if I had joined a group
when I went to the assignments tab it
would prompt me if I wanted to submit
assignment one and it would give this
warning like hey just so you know the
work you're about to submit is being
submitted for your full group it's
taking a long time to load which leaves
me a little bit nervous that lots of you
are downloading the data distribution
file right now in which case the
internet internet might slow to a crawl
but in any case that's what would happen
and I'm hoping it works out and the
other thing that I wanted to mention is
the reason that we created that we want
you to get different groups for the
different assignments and then the final
project is just that I couldn't tell
from the system whether or not if you
formed a group at the start you could
change it without having things go crazy
and so I thought the worst case scenario
people just reconstitute the same group
for each assignment and then the final
project maximum flexibility and it just
means that at some point you have to do
a whole lot of scrolling okay I'm going
to give up on that but I think it's
going okay let's get oriented a little
bit so here's the the main page for the
course which you can find by googling
cs2 - for you Stanford nice addition we
have a calendar now that shows all the
office hours that's a more intuitive
interface and it also is a reminder here
you can see that we have a special
session on Friday 3:15 our kind of
refresher or an intro to Python and
Jupiter notebooks
and Lucy and Ashkan two of our teaching
team are doing that and I took the
liberty of posting Lucy's Jupiter
notebook tutorial here
which is nice and interactive I think
you could use it with them and
and then going forward it has lots of
great tips about how to use notebooks
and you can also see everyone's office
hours including and is going to have
office hours on Saturday so if you're
working over the weekend he's available
in the in the Wang auditorium basement
another quick update so I did scroll
through this last time you can kind of
see our units where we're gonna start
building a foundation for NLU today and
then we kind of branch out and explore
some tasks largely in the service of
giving you a sense for what different
models you might use for your own
projects and so start building up some
best practices the one scheduling change
is I know a lot of you are probably
thinking about going off into industry
and maybe doing NLU in industry and so I
had scheduled the day on May 22 where I
was going to have like a panel of people
come in who are people who are doing NLU
in industry now and just kind of
interview them and get questions from
you all about what their experiences are
like to give you a sense for what's
happening out there in the world
I should have predicted this but it's
very hard to schedule people everyone is
very busy and so I think what we're
actually going to do is have two of
those panelists come on April 24 and
that'll be March a reticence who was a
postdoc here and did beautiful work on
Co ref very linguistically informed but
also successful on the engineering side
great work and she's been at Google for
a long time having gone kind of in and
out of eka damia and so I think she has
a really interesting story so she'll be
here on April 24 and she'll be joined by
young genteel who was a master student
year and is now working in industry
doing things like NLU for healthcare
i've worked quite closely with Guillaume
and he's also got an interesting story
to tell about why he decided to stick in
industry as opposed to pursuing a PhD
and another thing I like about
Guillaume's profile is that he's been
very helpful to me in producing lots of
notebooks as you can see here that kind
of show you how some of these interfaces
work and so for example if you look at
the tensorflow code that I distributed
for this course you can see that I have
like shamelessly ripped off all of his
best practices and tips and tricks for
doing tensor flow with these new
estimator classes so I feel indebted to
Guillaume
so they'll be here on April 24 and then
I think we will have a similar panel
discussion in late May on the 22nd and I
think I have successfully guilted bill
into being one of those panelists
because bill has an incredibly
interesting story where he started out
as a philosopher and did all this stuff
in finance and then did a PhD and now
he's played essentially every role you
can play doing things related to NLU in
industry so it'll be bill and maybe
somebody else I'll tell you more about
those things in the future and I think
I'll be soliciting questions from you
all that we could could ask these
panelists let's see you have a few other
assignments are some other announcements
I hope you've gotten set up with the
course materials there's a notebook here
for doing that and also I'm thankful to
go for posting a really detailed post on
Piazza about how to get set up with
things and we're going to try to
continue to do that kind of FAQ for the
assignments and other important aspects
of the course cost Piazza can be hard to
browse there's like lots of times in my
life where I've said oh this student is
the 12 student asking the same question
and then I can't find the 11 other posts
about exactly that topic on Piazza and I
feel sympathy for people just doing the
bread pose we're gonna try to gather
together all that information so that
it's available to you another
announcement Ignacio wanted me to make
we're gonna update the setup
instructions for people who might have
access to GPUs on their laptops like if
you have a Linux box but I think the
primary advice is if you want help
getting set up so that you could take
advantage of your local GP you come to
ignacio's office hours there he is he's
happy to help he says it's inevitably
going to be a mess but in the end you
can probably get it working together and
just a quick note about that I am
working very hard shamelessly asking as
many people as I can about getting you
caught cloud credits for doing projects
more details to come on that okay I
think that's it for announcements any
questions or comments before I dive in
yeah
I want to leave some time at the end to
talk about this in a little more detail
but the gist of it is the assignments
are nine points and they involve each
one of them involve setting up some
baseline systems for a task and then
developing your own original system then
you enter that system into the bake-off
and you get an extra point for just
entering and you get some extra credit
if you're the top-performing system in
the bake-off so it's a kind of little
project the assignment plus the bake-off
is a kind of little project and we're
trying to exemplify best practices as we
do that with the chance of having a
little win yeah that I think is like the
essence of what I wanted to say like
just the really important details so I'm
going to talk for example a lot about
vector comparison and re-weighting today
if you want the fast version you could
go to those screencasts it's like I've
tried to distill it down and do some
example calculations and I'm glad you
brought this up the way I think about
this unit here right now is we're on
April 3 we're doing distributed word
representations I'm going to be working
with these slides today and next time
and probably a little bit next week
simultaneous with that you could explore
these notebooks which also reinforce the
material but the nice thing about them
is they mix everything with code so you
could be hands-on all the way through in
a way that you just can't with a lecture
and then you could reinforce that with
these screencasts if you wanted to we
have a lot of coverage for the this
first unit because I think that the
backgrounds for you all are very
different I think some of you are in
like your fourth aai course and have
done lots of projects and some of you
are basically new to the field and this
is a way for us to kind of get everybody
we're on to a solid foundation but like
kind of officially none of this is
required you should just do what you can
we're making a lot of materials
available for you to get to build up
that foundation anything else before I
begin the
then slides for the for today are posted
here and they should carry us through
all the way to next week as I said the
reason you might want to download them
is that I am going to encourage you at
various points to do a little little
coding on your own so if you do have the
data distribution and you do have all
the code set up then I would encourage
you to like open a terminal or a
notebook if you want and paste in code
and then maybe play around with the code
okay just because you know it might lead
to new questions or give you a better
feel for what I'm talking about and I
hope you do a lot of that as part of
solving the homework problem one and
then just generally thinking about these
issues
all right so but let's begin with this
content so this is the unit on
distributed word representations this is
a big slideshow but you can navigate it
by clicking around up here if you have
it locally and it's pretty intuitive
this is our plot we're going to talk
about matrix designs comparison
re-weighting do a little sub word
modeling and then move on to
dimensionality reduction which here is
going to encompass LSA glove and word
Tyvek to give you a sense for kind of
the things people are doing in that
space and then the final unit is on
retrofitting where you might go beyond
just co-occurrence and bring in some
more structured information into these
representations so I hope that makes it
easier to navigate with what is a very
large slideshow yeah that's the kind of
the plan here and you can see it
reflected in that plot on the top here's
the big idea that you need to get used
to if you haven't already and I think
this idea is like incredible and subtle
and interesting so you can always just
continue to meditate on how and why it
works but the core idea is that if I
gather together into a matrix like this
a whole bunch of co-occurrence
information about words from large
collections of text then the resulting
representations we're going to think of
them as roads here in these matrices
those representations latent ly contain
lots of important information about
linguistic needs
some of you might have already be
familiar with that idea for some of you
it might sound really strange I can
still remember it sounding very strange
to me and I'm gonna try to make it seem
less strange to you but yeah this is a
co-occurrence matrix this is like our
starting point for the whole lecture
right it's a word by word matrix in the
sense that it's just counting the cell
values here are the number of times that
those words occur with each other and
the my pitch to you is that latent in
there is a whole bunch of really
interesting semantic information and
just one other way to plant this idea
here's a kind of little thought
experiment for you I've called this a
hopeless learning experiment on the Left
I have a little labeled data set of
words and you can kind of see that zero
for that class value means a negative
word in terms of sentiment and a 1 means
positive sentiment and that seems
perfectly sensible if you were to try to
generalize that information to this data
set over here where I haven't told you
what the words are of course this is
completely hopeless no matter what model
you have there's just no way that you're
going to be able to make predictions
about these anonymous new cases right
compare that with this much more
promising learning scenario so over on
the Left I have that same labeled data
set
except what I've done is represent each
word just with some numbers that
represent the Association of that word
with two other words excellent and
terrible and the kind of plot for this
course is I might have started with the
co-occurrence counts and have done a
bunch of massaging and stuff and gotten
down to more interesting values and
having done that it doesn't really
matter what your learning model is you
can just Intuit that like hey if a word
has zero class it likely has a high
terrible value right those are all these
values here and a highly negative
excellent value and then when I switch
to the positive ones it's the reverse
right they tend to be strong positive
and negative association association was
terrible and once you see that and you
can easily imagine that a machine
learning model would see this more or
less instantly then when I give you this
generalization problem
it's trivial to solve right and I think
that's one of the ways in which you can
start to see that latent in that
co-occurrence information especially if
I do some work there might be a lot of
important information about meaning yeah
so these are let's start let's start
thinking in a deep way about how these
vectors actually encode the semantic
information we're also going to build up
some foundational concepts that will be
with us throughout this course and
that's going to be a useful foundation
for the deep learning models that we
develop and also for you if you're maybe
just thinking about word meetings I
think this is a great toolkit for that
and then down the line what you might
end up doing with stuff that I introduce
now is kind of thinking about how these
representations are interesting for
linguistic problems or social problems
or whatever you decide to tackle or just
feeding them into other models because
they're a great starting point for the
reason that I just showed you they end
up encoding a whole lot of semantic
information and your model starts in a
really interesting place here are the
Associated materials which I've kind of
accumulated there are three notebooks
and they're kind of backed by this code
module that I'm going to encourage you
to play around with as I talk I'm gonna
try to leave some time today to talk
about homework one and bake-off one to
kind of reinforce the connections and
give you a feel for how that will work
and as I mentioned before they're a
bunch of screencasts for this and I
would think these are the core readings
we've posted some other ones but tourney
and Pentel is a great kind of compendium
of ideas and insights about these vector
space models Smith is a newer paper
that's kind of an informal introduction
along the lines that I just gave you
like why does any of this work and then
Pennington at all is the glove paper
probably talk about glove next week and
then Farooqi at all as a paper on
retrofitting which i think is a really
inspiring idea so I don't know
experience all of this through this
weekend next week some guiding
hypotheses I guess I just feel obligated
as somebody giving this lecture to give
this first quote at the top how many
people have heard that before
it's a kind of canard by now you shall
know a word by the company it keeps
firth has lots of quotes like this the
complete meaning of a word is always
contextual and no study of meaning apart
from context can be taken seriously I
also have a quote from bit consign the
meaning of the word is its use in the
language who knows really what Vic and I
meant but it sounds really I also have a
quote from Zelda Karras he was an
American structural linguist
strongly believed in this distributional
hypothesis distributional statements can
cover all of the material of a language
without requiring support from other
types of information that quotation and
actually also these first ones just as
an aside these are kind of interesting
because these linguists philosophically
were associated with this tradition of
nominalism which was kind of the view
that you could only trust things that
were more or less in the physical record
and so the one thing they felt they
could trust was the stuff that they
would see in corpora which really comes
down to just the distributional things
that they can observe so I have no idea
what they would make of the models that
I'm presenting you today I have a
feeling that they might be quite at odds
with their philosophical position but at
least superficially
it sounds like they're on our side and
then eternium until really argue
articulate the modern version of this
hypothesis if units of text have similar
vectors in a text frequency matrix they
tend to have similar meanings that's
kind of our guiding idea for now also by
way of steady at setting the stage and
kids giving you a sense for why this
lecture has the fluff that it does I
just wanted to walk you through this
overarching set of ideas here so if
you're gonna build one of these models
the first choice that you might make is
what your matrix design is going to be
like and I'm going to show you a few but
think like word by document that would
be words along the rows the columns
would be documents and the cell counts
would be the number of plans that those
words appeared in those documents so
that would be like not too tall
but incredibly wide if you had a really
big corpus word-by-word is the one that
I just showed you those are the two most
familiar designs but you could also have
a whole bunch of other notions of matrix
because you can have different notions
of context along those columns and those
will give you very different results
like this is a really fundamental issue
for building these representations but
that's not really the first choice that
you make because to build one of these
matrices you make lots and lots of
decisions about how you'll tokenize
whether you'll annotate how you'll chunk
up units of text whether you'll do some
feature selection for your vocabulary
and on and on right so these are all
design choices that you have to make
those feed into the matrix design and
then you might want to do some reading
because as you'll see today the raw
counts are not so good as
representations for meaning you have to
do some massaging as I said and so the
first way that you might massage is by
doing a reweighing to kind of amplify
the important things and diminish the
things that aren't so important and you
have lots of options there oh and I
wanted to say if you're experienced in
this space a kind of interesting thing
that emerges from this whole unit is
that the star of our show is point-wise
mutual information or PMI it's
incredible how often the insight behind
that re weighting scheme emerges in the
models that I'll present it's like the
hero of the story after we waiting you
might want to do some dimensionality
reduction and again you have lots of
options latent semantic analysis is one
that I'll show you but you might have
heard of some of these others like
latent dears light allocation or
principal components analysis and on and
on I'm not so concerned about these
acronyms
I'm just planting in your heads the idea
that if you're building one of these
things you have lots of options and then
finally you have to decide what vector
comparison method you're going to use
that's going to be like your fundamental
node
of what it means to be similar and if
you believe that tourney and pentelic
whoa that's pretty central here and
different notions of vector comparison
are going to give you very different
notions of what it means to be similar
one problem in this space is that
basically you can choose from any one of
these columns and get some kind of model
and there's not a whole lot of guidance
in the literature about what's sensible
and what isn't so this is like you're
kind of looking at a methodological
disaster zone right because I'm not
giving you much guidance about what to
do and there's untold number of things
that you could try I will say that in
the time that bill and I have been
teaching this course there have been
there has been some real progress on
this question I've kind of noted that
here models like glove and word Tyvek
which I'll show you later they kind of
attempt to unite or like take care of
rewedding and dimensionality reduction
and some of them even dictate what your
matrix design should be like and that's
a kind of like a way of saying that it's
one-stop shopping right if I choose
glove then I don't have so many design
choices or if I choose word Tyvek I
don't have so many different options to
explore and that's interesting you and
actually some of them might even
diminish the importance of which
comparison metric that you use because
of the scaling that they do on the
values so there has been some progress
but still you'll find actually the
bake-off and homework one are trying to
get you to confront this there's lots of
stuff that you can try and you might
feel like you're doing it kind of
blindly questions so far that's kind of
by way of introducing this stuff that's
my framework for these lectures okay so
let me just show you a few of these
matrix designs because already this is
important as I said so here's that word
by word one and I would say that it's
most salient property is that it's very
dense if you have a large enough corpus
most words will tend to co-occur with
most other words and so you get this
relatively few zeroes I mean there
aren't a whole lot of zeroes here in a
lot interval matrix there'll be a
substantial number of them all these
things are pretty sparse but this will
be like the densest
of all word by document that's another
common thing words along the roads
documents across the columns that will
be much sparser of course and if your
documents are short it will have an
incredible number of zeros in it very
different from the word by word one like
in the last word word word matrix when
we see is the column against and row of
means and that would mean the count of
against in all documents attached yeah
or some multiplying version thereof
depending on how you got the matrix but
yeah you could think of the diagonal is
giving just the token right this one is
kind of nice because it's not going to
grow very rapidly even as you introduce
more data the worst case scenario here
is like large vocab by large vocab so
like a hundred thousand by a hundred
thousand but you might have underlying
that a billion documents right whereas
this one is going to get big very fast
on the other hand this one will be
sparse so you might have some
interesting ways that you could
represent it in a way that actually
gives you some gains yep they're like
neighbors or would it be some like
that's that's a great question I want to
return to that because it's another one
of these design choices what you mean
when you say co-occur yeah let me just
show you a few more matrices and we'll
get to that here I just wanted to give
you a sense for a creative thinking
around this issue so this is a word by
discourse context matrix in the
switchboard dialogue act corpus you have
acts of dialogue and they've been
labeled with things like this is a
question or this is an introduction and
interjection or this is a bat-channel
and they're those are all these funny
symbols here and so I could create a
matrix of words by dialogue acts and
that would give me a very interesting
perspective on the usage patterns for
words very different from what we saw
before because the notion of context is
so different
and here's another one that's kind of
unusual and this one is less
distributional so this one is the
linguists will like this one I hope this
is phonological segments along the rows
those are symbols from the international
phonetic alphabet and then they have
their feature representations along the
columns like linguists do things like
saying this segment is plus voicing or
minus voicing and so that would be a
column there and you can and they have
lots of these I guess there's a 28
different dimensions that this font this
linguist has measured so it's not
distribution 'el it's more like a
feature representation and here's a
picture of it visualized and you can see
that's really good even if you don't
know this alphabet you can kind of see
like all these nasal end type things or
up here cut and good differ only by
their voicing and they've been clustered
together but otherwise they're very
similar here all these wrote exons and
and so forth and that's a nice
transitional idea what I'm showing you
here because what I showed you before is
all about co-occurrence in large corpora
this is more like a careful analysis of
these phonological segments and that's a
nice reminder that when you think about
these vector space models you're
actually doing something that's
pervasive in all of science which is
taking natural objects and representing
them with a handful of features that you
could measure I've given some other
examples here so I might just as
somebody doing more handcrafted work say
the movie was horrible is this vector
representation which is just counting
some abstract properties of that phrase
or this is even clearer like you might
model a human being like a subject in
your experiment as a vector 24 145 and
12 and that's just a reminder that you
might know that the first is an age and
the second is a weight but it really has
that meaning only because you're
embedding it in a larger data set where
the first column is the age and the
second one is the weight and that's the
sense in which those numbers have any
meaning at all and it's exactly the same
when we think about these co-occurrence
matrices the vector representations
acquire their meaning because they're
embedded
in a larger matrix and it's essentially
about those comparisons along the column
that you get meaning coming out of the
dimensions so the really special thing
about the models that we're exploring is
not that they're vectors but rather that
the vectors are coming from
co-occurrence counts maybe that's the
idea that you really need to get used to
which is that somehow just from seeing
all those associations in enough text
you can extract what we think of as a
semantic meaning and here I've listed
just a bunch of other designs by no
means means exhaustive but some of them
are kind of unusual and again I'm just
trying to hammer home the point that
this is a big deal like again if you're
thinking of building a Social Sciences
project on top of these representations
or you're thinking about developing
machine learning models this is your
first choice and it's going to have
really large impacts on the subsequent
results and there's lots of options that
you can pick from let's get to that the
final thing I want to address just for
this unit is the question that you
raised before which is what we think of
what we mean when we say co-occurrence
and I've kind of broken it down into two
things window and scaling so just by way
of making this concrete here I have part
of the first sentence of the novel
Finnegan's Wake which I chose because
the first sentence is also the last
sentence and so who knows where that
novel begins it ends that's kind of cool
for co-occurrence but just some abstract
text and what I've done is picked two as
our focal word in fact we want to
process the whole text so they're all
going to be focal words at some point
but let's just say we've we've honed in
on two and I've numbered going out from
there let's suppose that our window is
three we could impose a hard window and
what we would be saying at that point is
that to co-occur is to just be in that
window and obviously I could pick
different window sizes from one too it
could be as high a number as you wanted
right so that's a design choice and then
another choice that you might make is
how to scale the
co-occurrence counts so you know that
you have co-occurrence within the window
if I drink what I called flat scaling
here then I would be saying that each
one of these is a one standing for one
co-occurrence instance maybe that's the
default idea but I could also do
something more interesting which is to
scale those values so I might say that
to be closer is to be more meaningful in
terms of co-occurrence and as I get
farther out those numbers should
diminish because they're less strongly
associated and this is a standard thing
like 1 over N where n is the position
from the focal element that would give
you this like really rapid drop-off what
it meant to co-occur and you can imagine
mixing and matching these ideas right if
you set a really large window but you
have a scaling property like this at a
certain point it's going to be like
you're not co-occurring even if you're
in the window whereas with flat scaling
everything in the window counts equally
ya have the same weight regardless a
symmetric that is could I scale it
differently right and left right and I
think the answer is yes and it might be
reflecting a linguistic into intuition
that you have that may be things that
come after have a different different
weight different significance yeah and
the proof would be downstream and how
well your representations performed yeah
and you could have it scale at different
different strengths yeah I have a couple
of generalizations to offer here larger
flatter windows will capture more
semantic information because it's kind
of like what you're doing there is just
saying hey you're in the same topical
space as me whereas if you pick small
more scaled windows it's going to be
much more syntactic and collocation 'el
information because you're saying like
what I really care about is that you're
in this local linguistic environment and
so those matrices will encode a lot of
idiomatic information and a lot of stuff
that's just like hey this adjective
tends to modify this noun
which will be a very different picture
than the first one where you'll get
almost none of that information because
you were saying hey just being in this
document with me is enough to count as a
co-occurrence the other thing I want to
say is even if you've settled these
questions you probably still have some
design choices so you're gonna have to
impose some textual boundaries like you
might say that sentences or paragraphs
or documents or collections of documents
are your basic unit and that will
interact with what you choose for the
window right so for example if I was
focused on swerve here then as I go left
I just get a very narrow window but if I
decided that my textual boundary wasn't
that from but rather like stretched back
into the other part of the novel then I
would get different values for
co-occurrence and I'm gonna try to show
you that all this matters and one way
that you could start to get a feel for
how it matters is to do a little bit of
coding as I talk from now on so I
included these code snippets actually I
think I want to run them you should be
able to paste them out copy and paste
them out and it'll take a minute to load
while it loads let me just say that
here's the way I'm I'm trying to give
you exposure to a bunch of different
designs so what I have is two
fundamental data sets
I am DB movie reviews and Giga word so
IMDB that's like user-supplied reviews
of movies and Giga word is newswire
texts so already these are going to be
very different in terms of their
semantic content and you expect that to
be reflected in the representations that
we develop what I've also done is try to
pick two extremes so for each one you
have one version where the window size
is 5 and the scaling is 1 over N by what
I said before that should be a lot of
like collocation all syntactic
information and you also have one where
the window size is 20 that's really big
and it's the scaling is flat and if I'm
right about these generalizations then
you would expect that that's going to be
a lot of kind of topical information you
have that four Giga word and IMDB I
should say that all of these objects are
pandas dataframes
in my experience pandas is great it's
fast it's really flexible but it does
have a steep learning curve I've tried
in the notebooks to show you kind of how
to interact with these data frames if
you panic for an object just do dot
values and you'll be have an umpire rain
maybe it'll calm you down and you'll be
able to interact with it more truthfully
like for example I could do this and
that shows me a series what that's doing
is showing me in series form the entire
row for the word happy and that's a bit
weird so you might say dot values and
then you get you know the actual
representation in a more digestible
format all of these matrices have
they're all word by word and they're all
just five thousand by five thousand so
that's a pretty small vocabulary I want
you to be able to work with them pretty
quickly and we can't have you loading
massive objects into memory but I think
it's a pretty interesting vocabulary as
you'll see so they are meaningful spaces
to explore all right any questions so
far
okay so another major unit here is
vector comparison you've got your design
sorted out you've got a bunch of counts
let's say for now that it's word by word
and you want to think about that core
hypothesis that similarity in this space
is going to correspond to similarity of
meaning what does it mean to be similar
that will turn on what vector comparison
method that you choose I'm going to use
this as a running example this is also
the one that that appears in the
screencasts there it is as a tiny little
word by document matrix over there it
could be word by word as well and I've
also
so here's a down at two for B and C kind
of keyed into document X and document Y
and the conceit of this example is that
two things are happening with those
counts so first a and B are similar in
the sense that if you mentally kind of
rescale them then you can see that
there's more Y than X right the the
numbers are larger for y then for X so
that's the that's the sense in which a
and B is similar B and C are similar in
the sense that their overall magnitudes
intuitively are similar they both have
pretty large counts whereas a is pretty
small and you can see that here in the
way they've been plotted like a is kind
of lonely down in this corner and B and
C are up here pretty close together make
sense first distance measure Euclidean
distance this is the standard metric
that you might think of if you looked at
that example it's measuring just the
shortest point between a and B in the
plane here for two dimensions so you get
this dimension here in this dimension
here and it's the sum of the squares of
all these differences and then you take
the square root of it to rescale it
again and it's just reflecting what you
might think from the picture which is
that in Euclidean distance a and B are
very far apart and B and C are very
close together so it's already you I
mean the heart of this is that Euclidean
distance is favoring the magnitude over
that more abstract notion that I pitched
to you before about a and B kind of
being proportionally similar and that
might make you kind of unhappy as a
linguist because I contend that
abstractly speaking a and B are kind of
like for example superb and good both
are positive but superb is vastly less
frequent than good whereas B and C are
kind of like good and bad they're very
different in terms of their polarity but
in terms of their raw token counts
they're very similar
and I think this is borne out if you
look at these matrices that just kind of
having the same frequency is going to
give you very similar Euclidean distance
and that might be at odds with what you
want from semantics
I think frequency is correlated with
meaning I think it's not an accident
that's superb and terrible or infrequent
and good and bad or frequent but I
probably primarily care about that
polarity that sentiment information and
so Euclidean distance looks like it's
not my choice if that's my objective
well let's work on that a little bit so
once one way you could work on that is
by doing length normalization of these
vectors and the way that works is you
first calculate this quantity for the
vector that I'm going to call the l2
length there's lots of names for it's
like Euclidean norm and if you look on
Wikipedia it's a whole bunch of names
but there's the calculation there it's
the sum of the squares of all those
values and then you take the square root
and what you do to length normalize the
vector is defied divide each element in
the vector by that normalization
quantity and it gives you a new vector
down here here's a kind of look at how
that happens so if I start with that
original matrix I put in this column the
l2 lengths and then to get the new
matrix you just divide every element by
its corresponding row length l2 length
here's what happens to the space so
that's the original one on the left and
when I length normalize they kind of all
go up they're kind of all sitting here
in this unit sphere now and now a and B
are really close together and B and C
are far apart because what I've done
with this l2 norm here is kind of
abstract away from a lot of the
information about the overall magnitude
and that has pulled a and B together
what we're seeing is much more like
they're proportional comparison
cosine distance this is like the
workhorse of this this is the distance
measure that everybody uses if they
don't mention which distance measure
they used and I think there's a good
argument for that because what cosine
distance is doing is simultaneously a
Euclidean like comparison but in that
length normalized space here's the
calculation here the part after the
minus 1 minus is cosine similarity but
I've kind of regularized everything
about this framework in two distances so
I do 1 minus that value the numerator
there is the dot product of the two
vectors and the denominator is the
normalization factor and it's the
product of the 2 l2 lengths so this is
kind of like I'm doing this dot product
comparison but I'm also controlling for
the length of the vectors this is a look
at what the calculations are like a B
and C are sitting there in their
original positions but when you walk
through these calculations you find that
a and B are very close together 0.008
and B and C are pretty far apart 0.065
so cosine in one step is kind of
incorporating that length normalization
you can see that there in the
calculation and as a result it's
favoring that proportional similarity
that Sentiments similarity that I was
pitching to you another way to think
about this is if you first do the l2
norm and then you do cosine distance you
get exactly the same result I know it's
small but I've walked through the
calculations and the point it's just
that you get exactly the same values
whether or not you first do the
normalization or not and that's because
of the denominator there couple of hints
yeah go ahead
oh I should have checked this I meant to
I think that up to ranking if you first
length normalized then Euclidean
distance will give you the same rank
yeah so that that's the sense in which
like if you start to massage the space
your distance measure might not matter B
as if I first normalized all of these
vectors Euclidean and cosine are
probably going to be approximately the
same although I should check on the
exact relationship well I'm sort of
making up the sentiment part that's my
just so story about these things I do
think it's realistic I've focused on the
rows not the documents so I'm sort of
about how a and B are similar and how B
and C are similar not so much the
documents although I think you could
tell a similar story about the documents
yeah that ratio yeah that's kind of what
I meant and we can substantiate this in
lots of ways but you just like
articulated the core insight yeah like B
is the only one where the left value is
bigger than the right
once I adjust for their overall values
yes and then what I'm showing you here
is kind of a bunch of ways that you
could cash that out so one would be the
l2 norm and that does reflect that right
so I didn't make it so transparent but
once I've normalized in this way you can
see this one is bigger than this one and
those two are kind of very similar in
their proportional values other
questions that's kind of the heart of it
as I said cosine is a good default I
want to show you a few more just because
you might see them in the literature and
again there's some interesting things to
say about them so another popular family
of these comparison methods I've called
matching based methods so the matching
coefficient is the one that I've given
at the top there and you're just summing
up all of the smaller of the two values
pointless comparison across the vectors
that you want to compare
that's the matching coefficient and then
jacquard dice and overlap are all
defined in terms of that matching thing
so like matching matching matching in
the numerators and then you can see that
what they're doing is just normalizing
the vectors in different ways but that's
it yeah do you need to find Y cosine
work so well we just observe this one I
guess we should be careful about what it
means to work well because if your goal
was to really capture a lot of the raw
frequency values then it would be a poor
choice I think that it works well for
NLU problems because primarily we care
about what I'm calling the sentiment
Association we don't so much care that
Superb is less frequent than good we
care about how they're alike and so in
doing cosine you're kind of homing right
in on that but it's worth mentioning
that there's a danger to abstracting
away from frequency information and I'm
gonna you'll see that actually as we go
especially through these weighting
schemes that frequency is important in
language because it's important and also
because a lot of our data sets have
mistakes in them so infrequent events
you don't want to amplify them too much
so I don't know I think it depends on
the problem it's the sum of all the
smaller of the values that's sort of the
beginning and end of it what's behind
your question how can I substantiate
that
one way to think about this is that
sometimes you see all of these metrics
just to find four binary vectors and
then for example what dice reduces to is
the intersection over the Union and then
it's giving you some abstract measure of
overlap and then you can see that in
that context matching is like
intersection but when you move to
continuous values you can't just do a
straightforward set theoretic
intersection and the closest you can
come kind of in continuous space is the
smaller of the two because that's like
if I have a 0 and a 1 I'm going to get
the 0 and that corresponds to the
intersection idea if I have two ones
I'll get a 1 and again just like
intersection that's the best I can do is
there any other can anybody else help to
substantiate this what's going on with
matching maybe a concise way to say is
that any dimension that has zero is
gonna contribute nothing to the matching
score and intuitively there's no match
because there's a zero there and more
broadly any small number that's close to
zero contributes little to the metrics
yeah so in the previous slide you showed
your cosine distance between what do we
decide to normalize the
let's see let me see if I can unpack
that a little bit so in showing you
cosine with and without a first length
normalization step I was just trying to
get you to see that cosine is doing that
length normalization that's what its
denominator is doing and that's why it
doesn't matter whether I first like
normalize or just skip that step because
fundamentally it's building in that
rescaling that's all I meant there the
broader question of why you're
normalizing which you can see reflected
here because I could pick matching and
just use that or I can pick one that has
some kind of normalization that's kind
of like picking Euclidian or picking
cosine and this gets back to this deeper
issue of what am I doing when I abstract
away from some of the information about
the overall frequency and the vector
would use any of these you see these a
lot for ya we will talk about this later
I mean you see them all over so
presumably people have arguments for why
they've chosen them um you do see dice
in the context of binary vectors and I
can kind of see why that is because it's
equivalent to the f1 score which is a
very deep intuition about how we do kind
of basic metrics in NLU because it's
capturing kind of your the ability of
your model to reproduce maybe some human
behavior in an exact way capturing both
like all kinds of mistakes essentially
and so that doesn't surprise me that you
see dice sometimes but for the others
I'm just not sure it might not matter
too much maybe that's why people just
pick one
let me show you a few more and then I do
have some generalizations that I can
offer about how these relate to each
other be a little more precise about
that but just one more family that you
that you'll encounter that are
interesting to think about our kind of
probability based comparison methods one
of them is the KL divergence and this
isn't strictly speaking a distance
metric because you're comparing kind of
the deviation from the reference
distribution P to Q and this is the
value that you get here oh and I wanted
to say this can be a little bit fiddly
if Q I there for example is zero then
this whole value becomes undefined and
so you have to do a step for any
real-world application of kind of adding
some small value to all these things so
that your calculations don't explode and
that's one way in which kale is kind of
fiddly and the other is just the fact
that it's not symmetric so it matters
whether you pick P as your reference
distribution or Q here's an example of
it happening and I have to remind you
that because this is a probabilistic
notion you have to first normalize all
the vectors that is sum up their values
and then divide each value by that sum
so that you get a proper distribution
which imposes lots of other design
considerations like for example this has
to be a bunch of positive values so that
the normalization step makes sense
basically you have to be thinking I'm
going to use this only if it makes sense
for me to think of these values as a
probability distribution but if you're
in that kind of environment then this
might be a good choice I've given some
calculations here I know they're small I
think the fundamental thing to observe
is that like cosine and like length
normalization a and B come out very
close together and B and C far apart and
that's because of the probability step
that moves them kind of abstracts away
from their overall magnitude differences
and then here are the calculation
just to demystify all this notation and
so forth if you want to check that out
later
there are a bunch of variants that might
be interesting and are a little bit less
fiddly so one of them would be symmetric
KL the sum of the two values and then it
doesn't matter which you pick as your
reference distribution that's kind of
nice
KL divergence with skew gives you a
parameter that lets you control how much
you trust the reference distribution
versus the other one and you can kind of
like pull them together and then yin s--
and Shannon distance is a proper
distance metric that is defined by this
calculation which uses KL twice and a
nice thing about this is you don't have
to worry about that smoothing or
anything and it's symmetric it's a
proper distance metric right so this
will be like less fiddly than the other
options especially KL and I guess my
answer to why you might pick one of
these is just that maybe you're already
dealing with values that you think of as
probability values in which case these
are very natural metrics to choose let
me sum this up with a few relationships
and generalizations Euclidian jacquard
and dice with raw counts will favor raw
frequency over the distributional
patterns
that's my generalization there I showed
you two number two before euclidean with
l 2-norm vectors is equivalent to cosine
with regard to ranking oh that's a
firmer answer to your question I thought
I knew that from somewhere I guess I
learned it from an inch it's this
textbook so that's kind of nice because
then once you've normalized your space
it doesn't matter whether you pick
Euclidian or cosine jacquard and ice or
equivalent with regard to ranking you
can probably see that if you look at
their two definitions they just have
slightly different denominators
both l2 norms and probability
distributions can obscure differences in
the amount or strength of evidence which
can in turn have an effect on the
reliability of cosine normed Euclidean
and KL divergence and then skew which I
showed you briefly is KL but with us
that gives you lets you give special
credence to the reference distribution
any other questions or comments
yeah if you have a sparse dataset that
in English like one in Christ
concurrence might mess with the
frequency of the overall data set is
there a default
comparison method you should go use
again you're asking any question which
is like what to do with the fact that we
know these matrices have some problems I
think I have some a bunch of examples
that he write into this issue that
you're raising and I think it's not
purely about the comparison method but
also about what you're doing to the raw
counts so let me show you some examples
and then you could rear a z' this
question if it doesn't resolve them
finally here you're here are some code
snippets it's kind of small I guess but
I hope you can read it locally so I've
loaded this VSM that's from the course
repository and it contains a bunch of
functions that are useful for all the
stuff that I'm talking about now and
actually this example is from the
notebook here this is it this is the
space we've been working with a DC and
I'm just showing you here is for example
VSM euclidean with ABC looking at the a
vector and the B vector will give you
their euclidean distance as a return
value you can also do vector lengths you
can do length nor cosine matching
jacquard that might be all the ones that
I define in there yeah and you could add
your own if you want to I think I didn't
do KL because it's too fiddly but if
you're interested in kale its
straightforward to implement
oh and here oh this is this is kind of
more substantive so this is another set
of code snippets at the top there I just
reloaded for good measure that IMDB five
matrix and then I took the cosine
distance of good and excellent and it's
point nine six or so and then I did the
cosine distance of good and bad and it's
point nine four that's actually not what
I wanted right because I've been telling
you that we want to capture the
sentiment similarity in these spaces and
I think we can but so far those two very
similar words even with cosine our
farther apart than good and bad and
another way you can see that the counts
aren't so great you have this function
BSN neighbors and you can give it a word
and one of these vector spaces is the
second argument and it will give you a
series that gives you the ranking of
that word and all its closest neighbors
and the closest neighbors in IMDB five
too bad our guys a period tastes and guy
I think that validates something I've
been saying before does anyone want to
say do you agree yeah punctuation
shouldn't be treated as words I want to
defend the idea that punctuation could
be important so that's why I left them
in I guess we're both being provocative
about this I would want to say two
things first punctuation could be super
meaningful like exclamation mark versus
period versus question mark that'll be
important for lots of models but also if
you're right and the period shouldn't be
important then I should what's that oh
you did say okay but if somebody says
and you see lots of people with the stop
word lists where they're filtering off
lots of stuff that they regard is
unimportant a priori I say that's a
failure that your model should be able
to pick up on whether or not those
things are important and that's why I
deliberately left in a bunch of stuff
that you might think is junk I say if
it's junk your model should treat it as
junk I think punctuation could be good
what I just meant is that I told you
that
narrow window with scaling would capture
a lot of collocation 'el information and
it doesn't surprise me that bad guys is
a very common by gram in IMDB movie
reviews but it's also not such a happy
picture here and I did bad with jacquard
and it's a totally different picture
maybe less understandable in any case
this is kind of a cliffhanger for you
things aren't looking so good right with
these raw counts but we'll improve on it
and let's see I'm trying to yeah let me
show you one thing from this and then I
want to talk a little bit about the
homework because then we'll have lots of
tools under our belt so the next big
unit here is basic reading schemes and
again their goals are e weighting as I
said before we want to amplify the
things that are important and
trustworthy this is relevant for a
question I got before wait for your
question about idiosyncratic stuff we
want the trustworthy stuff that's
important and unusual but trustworthy
and we want to de-emphasize the mundane
and also the quirky and problematic and
so forth now absent a defined objective
function this is going to remain pretty
fuzzy but I think it's a pretty clear
idea intuitively the idea is that raw
counts have important information in
them but there are kind of poor proxy
for the things that we actually want to
care about but we can find the relevant
information if we look so I'm gonna show
you a bunch of these basically weighting
schemes and give you a feel for their
different properties and what I suggest
is a framework for thinking about what
they're doing is that you ask these
questions as we go so first how does the
reweighed set of values compared to the
raw countless for example if it was
identical to the raw counts it would be
not such a very interesting weighting
scheme right or if it was just a
proportional rescaling of the counts
then you might think why bother but if
it gives very different kind of values
from the raw counts then you might be on
to something you might also want to ask
how does it compare to the word
frequency which is kind of getting bad
that the steam I was articulating before
which is how much of these methods is
just capturing the fact that words have
different rates of usage and then
finally what is the overall distribution
of values you might know from other
linguistics classes that the
distribution of the raw counts is going
to be like this horrible zipfian
drop-off where a few words have very
high frequency and lots of words are
used hardly at all
and you might also have an intuition
that's that's kind of a terrible
distribution for lots of different
modeling that you might want to do so
you might ask of your rewetting scheme
that it gives you something better than
that crazy log blog as if being drop-off
yeah what's the difference between this
kind of waiting and like the scheming
that we did earlier yeah very similar
that's a good question when we did l
2-norm
and when we did probability
distributions I think we were doing
relating yeah they're kind of coupled oh
and I articulated this is a value before
I don't want to do feature selection
based on counts I don't want to get rid
of the most frequent words or you know
you stopped word dictionaries rather I
want the models to know that for this
data set it's not so interesting to have
used the words uh but maybe in another
data set that's an important property oh
this is a good way
connect with your question you just
asked so of the most basic kind of
relating that we could do would be
normalization and you've already seen
two ways of doing that before l 2-norm
'ok you know dividing all the values in
the row by its l2 length and probability
distribution which is just divides all
the values in the row by the sum of
those values that makes sense right but
it is a relating scheme and you can
already think about how it's gonna it's
going to be relevant here like you're
gonna lose a lot of frequency
information and gain a lot of really
rich picture of how things
proportionally
from each other observed over expected
this isn't involves a lot of notation
but I think it's a pretty intuitive idea
I just wanted to be precise so let me
just use Rho some X I to mean the sum of
all the values in row I and column sum
XJ to be the sum of all the values going
down that column and then sum of X is
the sum of all the values in the entire
matrix the observed over expected
calculation just takes each value in
your matrix and divides it by this value
the expected value
I think stepping back from the
calculations intuitively the way that
what this what this is saying is for a
given cell value if I think about the
probability of the column and the
probability of the row that's giving me
a default expectation for what that
count should be and then I can compare
that kind of default null hypothesis
expectation with the actual value and if
the actual value is larger than I would
expect given those row and column
probabilities
I want to amplify it and if it's smaller
I want to make it much smaller this is a
kind of like that phrase I gave you
before like amplify the important this
is like amplifying the things that are
departing from my default expectation
given the row in the column you're going
to see that again and again through all
of these weighting schemes and on
through glove and word Tyvek and all of
them it's kind of like null hypothesis
based on the row in the column and then
a comparison with what you actually have
yeah
that's the joint probability and
actually like I haven't done this year
but if you think about the sums that
you're doing like I have this counts up
here in these two sums here that's
actually if once I've done all through
all the calculations going to give me a
probability value and then the product
is the joint probability and down there
is the full probability for the whole
table which will be one so here's an
example of the calculations and I've
done some color highlighting here just
to show you what quantities are involved
for like first compute the row sum and
the column sum and then up here is the
actual count and then this gives you
that expected value down here
one more thing I'm going to return to
this next time because this is all
really important point wise mutual
information which I said is the hero of
this whole unit this is just observed
over expected in log space that's all it
is
and so PMI is also drawing on this
insight that I have a null hypothesis
based on the row in the column and then
I can compare that to the actual value
it just puts them into log space so that
you see many more differences than you
saw in that original space yeah so babe
usually you mentioned that kill
divergence is very big oh I just kill my
work death because he might very related
to whatever it is yeah and it's going to
be finicky this is this also relate to
your question you guys have the same
intuition and I've given an example
calculation here and what I've done is
just highlight this value so this is a 1
it's maybe maybe that's just a mistake
in your corpus that's what I'm asking
you to imagine but you can see that this
value if I compare it to its row and
column values is going to look huge
compared to these other ones and so I
formed this joint probability table with
the row and the column probabilities
this is kind of working off this version
and not this one but these are
equivalent
and then when I applied p.m. I look how
big that one has gotten compared to all
these other values and that's the like a
standard property which I think you're
keying into that often these log and log
odds comparison values really amplify
very small values that you cannot trust
and this is a problem with PMI is that
it does too much amplification of these
very small values and you'll definitely
see that if you use it if you look at
the tourney and pintail they consider
the laplacian smoothing which you
mentioned and they also consider a
method of contextual discounting which
is like adjusting the rows and the
columns a little bit but I think that
you know playing this forward a little
bit you'll see that glove is basically
regularize to reduce dimensional PMI you
might say oh well they just discovered
PMI then but that's not quite true
because what glove is doing is all that
stuff that you just mentioned and then
you might have a hypothesis which I
think is borne out that it suffers less
from this problem here I'm going to stop
here because I want to take the last few
minutes to just show you what the
homework is like I think we'll do that
again next time in a little more detail
and we're going to continue working
through this slideshow and call back on
previous themes but this is a good
moment to kind of plant in your ideas
that I think you now have all the tools
that you need to make progress on this
homework so I'll just describe the task
basically and then we'll wrap up and
we'll return to this later so the
homework and the bake-off are based
around a classic task in NLU for these
vector space models which is word
similarity I've given you for your
development phase five data sets these
are all kind of famous data sets from
the literature that are human curated so
like human annotation measures of
similarity four pairs of words so
they're all just these lists of two
words and then a score
and the overall task for you is to
develop a vector space model where when
you do comparison between vectors the
values that you get are proportional to
directly related to the ranking that the
humans have provided that is that they
reflect those similarity scores from
these human curated data sets that's the
heart of it I will say that there are
kind of two notions at work here
sometime the first three people call
those relatedness tasks and the second
two they call similarity tasks I'm not
going to make such a big deal about this
but you can imagine that the authors of
these data sets do make a big deal out
of it and you'll have to think for
yourself about whether you want your
model to key into one or another of
these notions so you'll do all your
development on these data sets and I've
given you some information about exactly
the metrics involved and then for the
bake-off I'm going to give you two new
data sets that you haven't seen before
and you'll have developed your system
and you'll simply run that system on
those two new data sets and we're all
kind of on the honor system here that
you don't do subsequent tuning to these
new data sets right the the way the
field works is we trust you to run at
once and report that score and that
should give you a good measure for how
well your model generalizes to new
notions of relatedness and/or similarity
the note book embeds all the readers
that you need and if you've already
downloaded the data distribution then
you basically won't have to fiddle with
any of this you can just read in all
these data sets
I do recommend looking at this code just
so that you know exactly what it's doing
but basically it's just reading in these
pairs of words with the scores there are
all the readers there and then in the
middle of this notebook I did a bunch of
stuff again trying to illustrate best
practices like if this were really your
project you would want to understand
these data sets and how they're related
to each other and you would want that
exploration to inform how you talked
about your model and your results and so
I've just done a bunch of analysis
unlike how the data sets
to each other at the level of vocabulary
and a lot at the level of the scores
they provide so that's the middle of
this notebook and you might want to
fiddle around with this to get a feel
for where you can tweak your model to
get improvements and then finally at the
bottom we get to the evaluation and this
is the the main thing that you'll want
to use so you have word similarity
evaluation which you know basically a
reader is a data set here and a DF data
frame that's the vector space model that
you created and then you can optionally
change the distance function if you want
and so that gives you a correlation
coefficient and the evaluation which has
a bunch of information in it there's
some stuff in here already for doing
error analysis which I recommend and
then finally here's the full evaluation
full word similarity evaluation if you
just feed in the vector space model that
you've built it will run it on all the
data sets and it gives you scores like
this for each one you can think of this
as my baseline and it's truly horrible
so like for example all I did was read
in Giga 5 so raw counts narrow window
heavy scaling you actually have a
negative correlation with Sim burb Devin
test and the other ones are pretty
dismal there's lots of room for
improvement over that baseline what the
homework questions ask you to do is
build up some interesting models so
first of all just do positive point wise
mutual information which I almost got to
I showed you PMI so you would do that
I'm going to do LSA with you next time
explore different launch of different
values of LSA will do glove maybe next
week I'm asked you do a little bit of
exploration of glove all of this is just
kind of coaxing you in directions that
might be interesting so you produce a
little bit of code t-test tree waiting
oh that's not what I'm going to talk
about in the lecture but that turns out
to be a really powerful REE weighting
scheme and if you stare at it you'll see
that it builds on this row column
intuition just the way PMI does so
you'll implement that and then
finally you just develop an original
system drawing on all those ideas that
you had before maybe you pipeline a
whole bunch of these models maybe you do
something that I never even mentioned
some crazy thing that you think will
work and you can hammer away at those
readers you can do as much evaluation as
you want don't over fit to them because
I'm gonna give you different data sets
to test on but you know do as much
development as you want and you submit
that and that's how you get nine of the
ten homework points on the day that the
submission is due which is April 15
we'll distribute those two new data sets
all you have to do at that point is run
the model that you developed on those
data sets and submit the resulting
notebook there's actually a like what we
want you to do is fill out these cells
down here but pretty much just submit
the completed thing and then you've
entered the bake-off so there's no real
work beyond just you know you have to
like paste in some code and then run
your system and then we're gonna see
what works best and once all the scores
are in we'll announce a winner and then
one of the TAS or a pair of the TAS is
going to reflect back to you everything
that we learned from looking at your
systems and thinking about the results
that we got and with luck having done
that not only did we have a fun
competition but we also learn something
about what works and what doesn't for
these problems all right
let's wrap up there we're off to a great
start next time a lot more reading